hello I'm sensually andrew heaton and
you're being seduced by mostly weekly
imagine you have a disability and your
doctor recommends a procedure for it it
lowers your blood pressure and increases
your antibodies it improves your mood
and it adds years to your life
now imagine that it's hard to access
this service and even when you do find a
person willing and trained to perform
the service you can't legally pay for it
and that's why we should legalize
medically assisted sex work thank you
it's so obvious so welcome to the world
of sex work and disability both involve
marginalized groups in society and both
mean you get to park in unusual places
and both sex workers and the disabled
community encountered loads of misguided
and preconceived notions about what
their lives are like now this new field
of study and practice goes by many names
in the United States but the most common
name is sex surrogate although I have a
few more suggestions myself sex
surrogates are called surrogates because
they are substitute sex partners for the
clients future romantic sex partners
surrogates simply stand in or kneel in
or Crouch em if you're into that
surrogates help clients flirt caress
dance perform oral sex orgasm and most
importantly learn about their sexuality
the clients of sex surrogates include
physically and mentally disabled adults
trauma survivors and other clients who
simply want an educational approach to
sex but not me I don't need help finding
a woman's clitoris it's inside the belly
button clients work with the talk
therapist who then recommends a sex
surrogate to help their client with an
experience that is slightly more
hands-on or toes on if you're into that
and this is an issue that affects a lot
of people one in eight Americans live
with a disability and the vast majority
of those people are sexually active even
more common is sexual dysfunction don't
believe me just check your spam folder
[Music]
sexual surrogacy was popularized in the
60s by William masters in Virginia
Johnson and somehow I managed to not
make an immature joke about two
sexologists named Willy masters and
Virginia Johnson thank you so much I'd
like to thank the Academy
the research duo popularized sex
surrogates as a way to treat clients
with an orgasm iya it's important to
note that surrogates take a more
educational approach to sex than most
sex workers also contrary to popular
belief many expert sexual surrogates are
men and they help female clients get to
know their bodies but Sarah Sarah
they'll be there when we're done so as I
was saying
Denyce Beckwith is a world-famous
swimmer with cerebral palsy and she had
this to say about her experience finding
a sex worker quote I really value that
experience because it gave me confidence
to then pursue other relationships so
sex work has an educated function so all
I'm saying is that if we legalize
medically assisted sex we too will win a
bronze medal in the freestyle at the
2000 Sydney games one of the reasons
that sexual dysfunction is so common is
because a lot of human sexuality remains
a mystery like how this man developed a
new erogenous zone in his thumb after an
accident left him paralyzed or how some
members of the disabled community
regained the ability to orgasm or where
the second clitoris is located sexual
surrogates help people discover these
answers for themselves and advance our
greater understanding of sexuality I'm
just saying we need to bone for science
purposes which by the way is the title
of my educational tape on how to pick up
ladies here's your clip hey speaking of
being misunderstood disabled people
often face unfair stereotypes and many
feel their sexuality gets ignored now a
lot of people with disabilities get it
on just fine without the need for sex
workers I mean look at Stephen Hawking
or FDR we're free to call Oh hot damn
all disabled yet famous partly for their
affairs and love stories but often times
heavily disabled people have limited
interactions with people other than
their caretakers who are often family
members that overlook their sexual needs
understandably look finding sexual
partners is hard enough even when you're
not dealing with a physical or mental
disability and sometimes sex is just sex
oh I got a match
and she's a robot but much like the
Clinton Foundation sexual surrogates
operate in a legal gray area and because
we aren't having a frank conversation
about every human being sexual needs
their amazing service is relegated to
the shadows but these services are
provided in other countries and have
already shown their value in the World
Congress on sexual health in Australia
in 2007 followed the study of 30 clients
suffering from a range of psychosexual
issues and they reported a success rate
of 95 percent 95 percent that's like the
approval rating of a North Korean
dictator medically assisted sex work is
beneficial to both the client and the
sex worker disabled adults are
especially vulnerable to psychological
stress and physical pain and guess what
is correlated with reductions in stress
and improvement in pain management what
is sex
really nobody's sex and on the other
side of the equation one of the biggest
concerns for a sex worker is physical
safety in when dealing with a physically
disabled client that isn't often a
concern in 1988 sex surrogate Cheryl
Cohen green performed sexual services
for journalist and poet mark O'Brien who
became paralytic from polio the story of
her helping him lose his virginity at
age 36 was made into a critically
acclaimed movie no not that one huh no
not quite that's the one so we can heap
awards and laurels on movies depicting
medical sex work but it's still
technically illegal but we're making
progress sexual surrogacy is gaining
social acceptance abroad and in places
like California where they is again
perform oral sex orgasm I'm not married
to any of you I can't say that word
clitoris plethora the thoris plethora
okay it's also with my favorite dinosaur